cette semaine le président sort de paris
emmanuel macron de nos coup d'envoi du
grand débat national
une sorte de tour de france de la parole
c'est la réponse imaginée à la
mobilisation des gilets jaunes en trois
mois les citoyens de france sont invités
à donner leur avis leur fiche de
solutions sur internet mais aussi lors
de discussions publiques
c'est un appel au débat au dialogue un
antidote aux affrontements entre
manifestants et policiers l'exercice est
inédit son issue est incertaine
d'abord on ne sait pas exactement tout
va y participer et débat pourrait être
dominée par des groupes d'intérêts
organisé aux demandes bien pointues
ensuite même les membres du gouvernement
hésite sont nombreux à craindre que leur
présence à ces événements un alimenter
controverse ou encore les colères puis
finalement on ne sait pas exactement ce
que sera le gouvernement de toutes ces
discussions d'abord des thèmes ont déjà
été écartée des débats
je suis en a fait savoir qu'il n'était
pas question de toucher à certaines
réformes qui ont déjà été posées aux
français même si elles ont contribué à
la mobilisation j'ai eu les jambes
bref le président inaugure ce grand
débat dans une ambiance d'improvisation
et de scepticisme
ils sont nombreux cancers à ne pas avoir
confiance que tout l'exercice débouche
sur quelque chose de concret